I saw the film was in New York screening
and I was just beaming with pride I just
was like he did it he did a movie that
was incredibly stylish but also smart
and thought-provoking and
congratulations it's just just a
beautiful beautiful film thank you I'm
glad it stayed with you I think that's
always important it's for me how I judge
a movie so thank you very much in the
fashion business for over 20 years that
had to have a huge influence on being a
director is it Tom Ford grows up and
wants to be a fashion you know creative
director fashion designer or does he
want to be a director or is it kind of a
culmination of all these visual things
put together it was a culmination of all
those visual things although I would
have loved to be a cosmetic surgeon as
well that's on stage because it's the
same it's architecture you know look at
the bones of someone's face it's about
seams where do you hide the seam how do
you reshape that how do you rebuild it
it's the type of aesthetics and I'm
quite fascinated with it it all rests I
could really improve breast implants you
know from an early childhood I love
design I love moving things around
telling stories I was always very good
at that
and telling stories visually which I
think fashion you know fashion sometimes
gets a short what's the word short
changed in some way because what we do
we really work hard out in fashion it's
a much more collaborative field than
people realize you have to have a vision
but then you have to communicate it to
the pattern makers the shoe maker you
know your team the guy who's building
your sets the person is working on your
music for the show and then you have to
support these people and then you have
to steer and guide all of that to help
realize your vision exactly the same
skill set you need as a director guiding
a team of people so your intuition plays
into it a lot of its own
in our business that's all you have you
know marketing reports and selling
reports and all this stuff can tell you
what's in store now so I didn't tell you
what's there tomorrow your intuition
tells you that so anyone who's
successful in the fashion industry uses
their intuition the more you do go with
your gut with your intuition the more
you're really giving a gift to people
out there something original
they're both industries to where things
look the lawson fabulous on yes the
amount of work and energy that goes into
both industries on the back the public
doesn't see so interesting you said that
because that's what we loved I'm just
gonna keep saying this over and over
again but this is a very visually rich
movie but it's it's the clothes and the
style did not overpower the nuances of
the performances starting with Colin
Firth who I think did a phenomenal job
and I've never seen him look so good
what did you do to comfort to make him
look so good I looked at the shape of
Colin's head Colin's hair in natural
life I think is distracts from the shape
of his head so I knew instantly Colin we
need to brush your hair he was really
nervous about cutting his hair on the
sides you wouldn't let the hairdresser
do it I actually had to do it I got down
on my knees and I said Colin I promise
I'm gonna do one snip at a time and then
you know the glasses and the clothes and
we aged him a bit so the hair is you
know gray and I'm glad you thought he
looked good I thought he looked gorgeous
are they so handsome and because it was
a character he was comfortable with it
because he needed to become George did
the movie influence at all where you're
taking Tom Ford or at least a part of it
I've always loved big lapels like from
the 1930s or the 1970s so my lapels will
probably always be a little bigger than
everyone else's however when I did this
film you know I fell in love with George
I helped create George I created George
and we have a lot of customers that come
in the store who like smaller lapels who
sometimes find our lapels to be too big
okay we should offer to our cost
a smaller lapels in the book George
doesn't have a last name so I had to
give me one last name again in the name
Falconer and we called the suit Falconer
and now you can get two different cuts
you can get a peek pal like George's
blazer or you can get a suit in the same
cut different fabrics and range of
fabrics are there certain elements in a
guy's wardrobe that you that are eternal
a man needs blazer pair of jeans
beautiful pair of shoes beautiful watch
we've all heard this before
a perfect tuxedo a good dark suit a tie
that's it you can go to anything and go
to a wedding and go to a funeral you can
go to a dinner party you can go to the
you know you can go anywhere with that
that's it in your mind who is the most
stylish man on earth and why la po L can
just wacky as hell style but never looks
foolish if you use them as inspiration
and I have and I do all the time by the
way things that work on la PO a lot of
people look like clowns in knives mean
crazy when people say oh I should have
lived in the 30s it was so glamorous and
looking like an absolute slob it's white
go buy a beautiful suit go write vintage
store if you can't afford it
thank you Tom pardon thank you
[Music]